Nothing Gold Can Stay
nothing even with gold hewed redheaded
beards like Oliver Anthony
can stay
conservatives loved Oliver Anthony he's
the guy with the dobro guitar in the
woods with the very slick high
production quality music video that was
presented as a Creed occur from a guy
with a handicam in the middle of the
woods and he sang about the rich man
north of Richmond
close to near run and the conservatives
rallied around him and made him the
biggest star in the country and then
now Oliver Anthony is irritated by that
and he doesn't want conservatives
claiming his music
it's aggravating seeing people on
conservative news try to identify with
me like I'm one of them
it's aggravating seeing certain
musicians and politicians act like we're
buddies and and act like we're fighting
the same struggle here like it was
trying to present the same message uh
you know I've had a lot of people reach
out to me and I tried to be polite to
everybody and um
I've talked to hundreds of people the
last two weeks but it seems like certain
people want to just
ride the attention of the song that
maybe make them their own cells relevant
and that's aggravating as hell the other
thing that I find aggravating is uh
well you know like it was funny seeing
my song in the
it was fun it was funny seeing it at the
presidential debate
because it's like I wrote that song
about those people you know so for them
to have to sit there and listen to that
uh that cracks me up
uh but it was funny kind of seeing the
response to it like that song has
nothing to do with Joe Biden you know
it's a lot bigger than Joe Biden
um
that song is written about the people on
the on that stage and a lot more too not
just them but but definitely them
all right little little incoherent here
this is what I pointed out about Oliver
Anthony's Song which I I thought showed
clear Talent he's obviously a pretty
talented foxy artist but the lyrics
didn't make a ton of sense because they
melded new populist impulses
with
kind of generic establishment Chamber of
Commerce GOP complaints about welfare
queens and things like that so I said
the lyrics aren't totally coherent but
as far as a first shot goes musically he
said he at least has a good voice the
the whole character and Persona works
pretty well no wonder that the the video
went viral uh now he's saying look this
song this has nothing to do with Joe
Biden it's it's about much more than Joe
Biden well hold on which is again this
is contradictory is does it have nothing
to do with Joe Biden or is it about Joe
Biden and the whole political system
well he seems to be
saying both things at once but but he's
really focused on Republicans he's
saying no it's the guys on the
Republican debate stage that I was
singing about they're the ones that I'm
complaining about not Joe Biden it's the
Republicans and there's some evidence
that the guy is a Democrat he there was
some Facebook post I saw going around I
think it was authentic in which he was
complimenting Joe Biden there's a video
of him just mumbling through the classic
liberal platitudes about you know the
truth this true strength of America is
our diversity
I mean we are the Melting Pot of the
world and that that's what makes us
strong is our diversity and we need to
learn to harness that and appreciate it
and not use it as a political tool to
keep everyone separate from each other
you know so that that kind of a
statement I mean we all like people of
different cultures and things like that
but the statement diversity is our
strength that is a very modern extremely
liberal slogan that is used to justify
Mass migration and to displace and to
injure the very working class that this
guy is supposedly singing about he then
tweets out he says I don't support
either side politically not the left not
the right I'm about supporting people
and restoring local communities now go
breathe some fresh air and relax please
I'm not worth obsessing over I promise
go spend times with your loved one okay
I'm not gonna be too harsh on Oliver
Anthony because I think what he's doing
here is probably smart right now text
nulls to 200 to 300 for most homeowners
window replacement is not something that
they've done before for many it is not
something they want to do but rather
something they have to do if you've put
off replacing the windows in your home
because it's too expensive I've got
great news for you you can call now to
get a free in-home window consultation
and a free price quote from Renewal by
Anderson Renewal by Anderson's signature
service is committed to giving you the
best customer experience possible
supported by the best people in the
industry the superior process and an
exclusive product someone just wrote
into my show the other day after hearing
me mention Renewal by Anderson and said
he's a carpenter and he said that when
he goes in and sees the work done by
Renewal by Anderson it is so far ahead
of the competition it's not even close
this guy was not it doesn't work for
Renewal by Anderson this wasn't
solicited he just wrote in because he
heard about I have a cousin who works
for these guys from what I hear they are
just the absolute best in the business
so right now Renewal by Anderson is
offering a free in-home or virtual
consultation on durable quality
affordable windows or patio doors for
zero dollars down zero payments zero
interest for one year text Knowles
Canada wlas to 200 300 for your free
consultation to save 375 bucks off every
window and 750 bucks off every door
these savings will not last long be sure
to check it out by texting Knowles to
200 300 that is nulls to 200 300 texting
privacy policy in terms and conditions
posted to textplan.us texting enrolls
for recurring automated text marketing
messages messaging data rates may apply
reply stop to opt out go to
windowappointmentnow.com for full offer
details Oliver Anthony doesn't want to
be ghettoized into the conservative
media sphere where he becomes you know
the favorite folksy singer of a handful
of shows like this show this show maybe
a few other podcasts maybe a couple
shows on Fox News and that's it that's
going to be his career no he he wants to
be mainstream he's gotten a taste of
Fame and money and he he wants to be a
real player who can sell out stadia and
go on all sorts of other shows so okay
fine what's my
suspicion here
I don't think that Oliver Anthony has
any particular
political philosophy or ideology
I don't think that Oliver Anthony just
one day accidentally stumbled on Fame I
don't think he walked out into the woods
with his dogs in this dobro and just set
up a little camcorder and then just
accidentally went viral I think this is
a guy who's been a struggling songwriter
for a long time who
saw his opportunity and made a bet on a
very slickly produced music video and
made the right kind of connection so
that the video could go viral and he
prepared to meet the opportunity that
came along and that opportunity came
along because of a specific moment in
our culture
that's the key
I don't think this guy has changed
popular music or popular art I think
this guy saw which way the wind was
blowing and he took his opportunity this
happens all the time in movies this
happens all the time in music
you have one hit
you got one little hint oh our war
movies are in now okay then you're gonna
get a glut of war movies
this particular brand of pop music is in
okay this one band does really where
you're gonna get a whole bunch of other
Pretenders who who try to copy that act
and I think here since especially since
the election of Donald Trump
especially since the rise of populism
nationalism here in Britain in Europe
this has been building for some years
now
this guy saw okay this is the moment for
a Creed occur about the Forgotten men
and women of America you saw the success
of JD Vance's book hillbilly allergy
turned into a big movie One JD a senate
seat
it's it's not as though the signs
weren't there and this guy met his
moments this is why I really like the
Oliver Anthony phenomenon
I don't have any particular interest in
Oliver Anthony or even in his song
but I do like that a guy who was
prepared to meet opportunity at a pretty
sharp Observer of culture
saw that the culture is moving in a
direction that is very favorable to us
now maybe the ruling class will just
clamp down on that and continue to rig
the elections and continue to censor
conservatives and continue to
incentivize even the people who become
famous as conservatives to to disavow
all of us and everything we believe
maybe that'll happen maybe the Liberals
just have too much power but the wind is
blowing in our Direction no question
about it boy what a great clip that was
huh now make sure that you ring the bell
subscribe to the Michael Knowles YouTube
channel we'll see you next time